I'm sorry do you mean turn it up and
then go no 22-inch pose so turn it up
then that's what I would do and then I
go get fired I'm sure yeah your bodies
your body its look it looks fantastic
take as many pictures often get and put
your bathing suit on and take a million
pictures walk around in your boxes just
look when you're open your front camera
be like yeah this is gonna sound crazy
to a person if this person is under 50
you could not do social media
Tina nobody you could you could not do
it Tina but how are people gonna know
that I had a party how do I see where
people are when I'm not with them and
how do they know where I got it that how
do I feel left out about not being
invited to the thing they're at yes your
body will find a way but also just yet
everyone's curating their life and it's
like if you're really living your life
you have no time for that about Isis
yeah not about that
the angry teacher no no no mr. Wilson
how do you get over it huh maybe just
off it just been in yes my mother-in-law
who I left before I got married she said
so my only advice for marriage is don't
fuss too much she's a little southern
lady and it's so true it's like it
sometimes and you're not really mad
about it don't like make yourself mad
about it because you think you should be
my Nana my Irish Nana used to have a lot
of good little sayings one of them I
like is stranger she'd be a little
strange which is just like I'd be able
little bit suspicious of people that are
too friendly to too soon and very Irish
or she would say you're as busy as a
one-armed paper hanger which was funny
or if you lost something she'd say look
where it is and you'll find it
oh uh how much was in theory